hey guys welcome back to the evan and
katelyn podcast the podcast that
evidently doesn't get made unless we are
very sick
[Music]
so as you can tell by the title and our
general overall disposition we did get
covered it has stunk very greatly very
greatly well we're not just going to be
talking about that we're also going to
sit down and talk about what we've been
up to the past
nine days while we've been under the
weather and um kind of
an overall
trend that we've noticed with youtubers
starting out really strong and then over
time
fading their output or enthusiasm or
something like that and some theories we
have on that because it's something that
we kind of
were
re-introduced to while we were going
through
all of our
200 and uh
supporter only videos and we'll talk
about that a little bit later um but
speaking of
our supporter only videos our supporters
over on patreon on youtube we want to
give
all like a couple thousand of you guys a
huge thank you very much for your
support when we're sick like this you
know it's it's pretty stressful to think
that like you know we are the whole
business
we are the whole company and without
creating content
like our whole income stream is creating
content and like honestly guys we
haven't been able to create like
any content no talking is hard
yeah and like this is the best we have
been after like like
it's probably been 11 days for me and
nine days for you at this point
we are trying very hard to not cough
and to clear our throat as minimally as
possible yeah i can already feel it like
building up i know
i'm getting kind of hot
if you need to take a break throat
clearing
if there's little moments of silence
like that it's just like us coughing
violence yeah we can mute our mics yeah
um
uh oh yeah i was saying uh thank you
guys for for all of your ongoing support
because um you know when we when we
can't create content that's like the
main income that we can count on so it's
really nice
knowing that you guys have our back and
one of the things we've been up to
during the past nine days or so while
we've been really under the weather is
uploading our entire library of 213
supporter only videos
to
our official evan and caitlin youtube
page for those of you guys watching
the youtube video i'll kind of show you
where the videos have ended up so if you
go to our evan and kaitlyn youtube page
and you scroll down you'll see our
uploads our popular uploads some other
playlists some of our channels and we
actually have a whole playlist here of
members and patreon only videos and you
know we have 158 after shows
um
we have 50 mini vlogs and uh seven
videos that just didn't really fall
under either of those kind of
miscellaneous and
um it's been it's been really
interesting caitlin was the main person
who took it on but i kind of started it
but it was really interesting going back
and like watching
some of the like behind the scenes
videos because when we first started
making youtube videos
we tried to script it all and we tried
to
you know get around us really not
knowing how to present
through scripting and through
not doing much in the moment in person
talking so it's really interesting kind
of going back and watching
us when we are first starting to like
just
casually talk to the camera
casually yes yes casually or like like
pretending to be casual but like being
very hard trying really hard to be
casual
yeah
i mean i think most people that try
making videos
go through some sort of period where
it is like
more difficult to
talk to the camera off the cuff
um we just kind of went through that on
patreon instead of
like fully publicly yeah and i think
that was that was kind of interesting
but also going back through these really
old videos i kind of forgot how
stressful
various of these time periods oh my gosh
oh my gosh like so many of these videos
start out with i was like hey guys we're
really loopy we haven't been sleeping
very much we're working on five videos
at the same time
like just like really
kind of
being honest with with everyone behind
the scenes but like i think that like
that was a period of time where i
haven't thought about that much and i
kind of forgot how
stressful and tired we were back then i
think i have thought about it more than
you because
there have been many periods even
recently where like things got a little
stressful or a sponsored deadline was
kind of tight
and to me
like
for most of it even if i get stressed i
can kind of logic my way out of like
okay it's not that bad because i think
back to when it was
truly stressful
yeah
yeah back when we were trying to do you
know four to six
videos a month sometimes on our main
channel and our projects were even
bigger
you know often times during those chunks
and we didn't have as much on our plate
in other ways no it was a lot of that
was like before we started the gaming
channel and the podcast before we did
second channel stuff yeah um
but still the main channel videos take
the most time so yeah yeah and i think
another thing though that's interesting
i mean this is kind of going a little
bit off topic we didn't really plan to
talk about this but i think also
back
when we were
filming videos in a more like get b-roll
and talk about it afterwards i was able
to just do a lot of the project
while you were editing and everything
like that and now we do a lot more
in-person talking we do a lot more like
long-form
filming where we just film for long
chunks of time which i think captures
more good moments but it also
takes longer
and it it takes longer to make in that
situation and it takes longer to edit in
that situation since a lot of things
have changed from back then that is true
but it was interesting going back
and
seeing
that change especially like
our exhaustion levels so i'm like well
we're a lot less exhausted
excluded has themselves excluded it's
been hard to get sleep and we've needed
so much more sleep like all just
randomly in the middle of the day just
like pass out
just like yeah
i'm just like going about my day and
then i'm like okay peace
yeah i just like pass out for an hour
and a half two hours
yeah i know like it affects everyone
differently and um so we had two
vaccines
but we were due for a booster like right
around the holidays and we're kicking
ourselves because we didn't do it
because we because we were trying to we
were worried that the booster would make
us feel sick for a couple days because
the second shot did
and we were trying so hard
to like film film film film film
everything we needed to get done before
the holidays so we could actually take
some time off and we're like if we're
sick for a couple days
we can't film yeah so let's wait till
after the holidays to get our booster
yeah that was a mistake yeah and
thankfully none of our families on
either side yeah no one have
yeah it's just us but i mean everyone
else in our families has their booster i
know we're the only ones yeah and like
that that was one of the things that
like it was like
there have been many wake-up calls that
we need to like change
kind of the path that we're on and we've
been changing towards a more sustainable
path for a long time this is another
thing it's like if if we
are prioritizing work over like you know
getting a booster
and stuff yeah like if we can't take you
know if we can't risk
two days
yeah of of being you know under the
weather for our business i think that
that's like just another one of these
signs that are like okay we need to
we need to rethink some things yeah
basically yeah we need to
build in
more additional time for when things
like this come up because things always
happen things always happen things
always happen and it's really hard when
like you don't have weekends to like
absorb the extra things that pop up yeah
so i think we're going to talk about
that more as a big topic later on um but
i'll wrap up what else we've been up to
honestly it's been like uh uploading
this entire library of videos to youtube
and
as a side note about that it's not gonna
affect patreon at all no it's not gonna
affect patreon
like if you're a patron patreon member
we're still gonna post a patreon post on
patreon
um
it more so
is like a benefit to the youtube members
because in the past it's really hard to
go back and find that library if you're
a youtube member if you're a patreon
member you can at least like filter by
after show post
on patreon yeah but it's been really
hard for members so it's it's not going
to like
change anything or take anything away
from anybody it's just an additional
way for youtube members to see it well
also i think that when we started
youtube memberships we started
um equally posting whatever we you know
most like to the best degree that we can
everything we post on patreon we post on
youtube memberships but we never went
backwards
yeah and uploaded our full library to
youtube so so patreon was still
the only place to get our full library
of exclusive stuff
and we just didn't
want that inequity between the two
options yeah for people who you know
might want youtube over patreon you know
it's like i think that that from our
perspective you know
patreon takes less fees
um takes lower percentage so we still
love patreon and we're still going to be
putting a lot of you know the same
effort that we always do but we just
wanted
to do i feel like we just like we're
we're kind of paying that we weren't
doing things in our in our head like the
right way
and whenever something is not being done
the right way it pains us
and that's another thing we're going to
be talking about later because like in
in the like
mad rush to start a youtube channel
and and just all of the work that's
involved in that a trail of destruction
is often left behind you you know what i
mean
i do i don't know if they do i know but
we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about that later um so
that's what we've been doing we've been
kind of taking some time to clean up
behind us um we've also just been
playing video games honestly i've been
playing a lot of seven days today yeah
you know it's it's it's just such a fun
we're on day what day are we on like
unlike
yeah we're in the 50s we have an epic
mega awesome i feel a little guilty
because we
played all the seven days to die and we
didn't stream it obviously we couldn't
have streamed it because we were very
sick talk and we couldn't talk
we were just sitting here in mostly
silence occasionally coughing
or like you know like hey can you
collect some trees or let's go raid this
area yeah or like you know
minor things and we just watch we're
just watching content like we're
consuming content while we're just
playing seven days to die we're not
we didn't have that like this is the
first day that we felt like we could
talk for an extended period of time
yeah and we're gonna see how it goes and
then maybe think about scheduling a
stream
yeah yeah this is like a dry run for
stream yeah after after this we'll see
how bad our voices and coughs are
affected
and then we'll see but it's been really
kind of fun just to play video games
with you yeah it has been nice i mean i
know we do it a lot for work but it's
also
it has been nice just like playing with
you
in a chill
low energy way yeah
as well yeah we've also uh we have this
this mythical
scary day so we'll like we run our lives
off of two things air table for like
it's like a basically a super fancy
spreadsheet where we have like all of
our project management and we have like
you know editor management and we have
like all of the top level big stuff and
that's where we like run
the high level of our business and then
we have a to-do list that we share
between us and that's how we run our
everyday today you know we we tackle
this and that we can assign things to
each other or ourselves and we have
notes and all that stuff and uh we have
this like day called the miscellaneous
day it's usually like one day per week
that we we push
all of the things that we don't have
time for that aren't really urgent
but are
like important enough to not
like remove
and we've been attacking a lot of these
like miscellaneous things that we know
that we need to do
i'm just gonna step in real quick it's
not you said we have it like once a week
no i got once a month
no oh
we we have a day
yeah
there's items on this like
sometimes we'll call it lego on on
magical tuesday
we're gonna
do all the stuff just move everything to
next tuesday
you know usually because like the end of
some deadline will be monday so we'll
like just put it on tuesday put it on
tuesday well right now it's on the uh on
january 16th we have like that's the
magical day for now and by like before
we get to the 16th we're going to like
look at it and say no we can't do all of
that and we're going to push it to the
30th yeah and so it's um it's not that
it's scheduled on any regular cadence
it's just always moving
it is always being postponed but we did
we've tackled some of those we did
tackle a few of those things yes
while we were sick because we also
like
we did try to rest some we played video
games and we like tried to sleep a lot
more but we also we did sleep a lot
get a lot of
anxiety if we go too long without doing
any work we tried to limit it to chill
work that didn't require any talking
which is why
we tackled the huge you know uploading
of 213
videos and some of the miscellaneous
tasks um but we did chip away at it a
little bit yeah i don't know i don't
yeah i just don't know if we had ever
talked about the scary miscellaneous day
that we always put off magical tuesday
magical tuesday or sunday or whatever
day it's on it's a magical day because
somehow everything on that list
right now it's a sunday yeah yeah
honestly though like one of the biggest
single line items on that list
is the one that we tackled the uploading
the um
213 videos i mean that what that took
days days and days of like solid effort
honestly like yeah perfect effort to do
whatever
20 hours 30 hours
yeah like a long time a long time
yeah so that's that's what we've been up
to while sick very exciting very
exciting stuff
um
but uh yeah i think that uh
one one topic that's been on our minds
for years years years years
you know is we've we've always been
aware
like of creator burnout
probably because like when we started
four years ago there were already
youtube creators burning out
yeah
and that's something that we've seen
even still like you know our uh one one
of the
youtuber that we have collaborated with
and stayed in touch with william osmond
just had to take a break because
everything got too much for him too
and it's it's still happening all over
the place not just people getting
overwhelmed um for for you know
the
there's just all the different pressures
that can hit you from all different
directions so it's been on our mind from
the beginning to try to avoid
burning out and we kind of knew in the
beginning like the first few years
that we would be working at an
unsustainable pace and over
the last maybe
year
really we've tried to um
like rain things in a little bit like
pull back
a little bit
um
of course then we also like started
other stuff
like you know
started doing more in the second channel
and
more on the gaming and things but
overall it still has resulted in us
tackling a slightly more manageable
amount of work
um
but that
it's just manageable by comparison like
we still
haven't had weekends ever so um
we are gonna try this coming year to
build in a little bit extra time
and if we happen to have the extra time
and energy to
like throw in another video here and
there awesome but we're going to try to
like
not pre-commit
to as many i think we can go a little
bit more behind the scenes here and get
a little bit more specific we
pre-sell
ad deals
yes to to companies that we have these
long-term great relationships with
and we have pre-committed ourselves to a
certain number of videos in the past
and i think that the the level of videos
that we have committed ourselves to
requires us to be at full health and
full productivity for the entire year
and it's just it's just uh you know who
knows maybe you get appendicitis maybe
you get covet maybe
maybe you move maybe
just a few recent examples
you know but there's always something
disrupting your life like we
we've learned again and again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again and again
over the past four years that you just
can't
assume that your life is going to go
super smooth
um so i think that the big thing that
we're going to try to do is pre-commit
to less videos
and then if we have
the ability to make more videos
then we can release them or try to find
a sponsor for them or what have you you
know what i mean and then we'll be able
to
we'll be outputting the perfect amount
you know what i mean the the
the amount that is sustainable for us
that we're really happy with and all of
that i mean that's the hope every year
we're guessing at what that amount is
going to be and we've so far been wrong
every year yeah so far we've been wrong
every year so far it's been
a little hard to keep up with but yeah
um i mean even even in 2022 the year
that we're in right now yeah we uh
try to choose a reasonable amount and we
are patting ourselves on the back like
yes
yes we did it and i think we calculated
we freed up like
42 days
i don't remember the night or something
like that and then we're like yes that's
so many days
and then we did the math
like and it's still like less than one
day per week off so we're like dang it
we still have weekends
but you know it's better it's better if
we will do it
who knows if we will
yeah but i think i think that's
something that's been on our our mind a
lot um and i think it's a pattern that
we've noticed with other youtubers too
because i think that
that it's it's so easy
to like start off at an unsustainable
pace and then also you almost have to
yeah like in order to get the momentum
you need to grow in the beginning like
you almost have to be unsustainable it
feels
i remember the year where were you like
did we do one year where we did
all the collaborations and all the
events over those two separate years i
think it was over like a year and a half
year and a half where we were traveling
basically every month either to
an event or a co-lab yeah
that was that was a stressful year that
was just fun but it was awesome yeah
that was that was really fun like part
of me is like ah let's just do it again
that sounds so fun no
not at that pace
i mean it would be fun to go to events
or like do a collab here and there but
um not not at that pace
that was too much yeah i think that that
other things for us that that have been
starting to to get to to me even and
honestly i don't even know how caitlyn
has like put up with this for so long
caitlyn i'm not sure if you guys know
caitlyn loves
tidiness
yes order yes organization yes
everything having a place and everything
in its place
yeah we haven't had that since we
started the channel
caitlin like had a
a blog
before we started dating
where she would like you know
like decorating in my apartment and
stuff yeah but oh my gosh your apartment
was so neat and tidy
immaculate and it was decorated per
season
it was yes
and like especially for halloween yes
and i think that that stuff like that
you know with with the the
like our work as busy it is as it is and
like with our work like bringing in so
much physical items into our house
it really does it's been so chaotic it
was so funny we um but
i'm just gonna say give you some praise
you have been so good you've been so
good with not letting it get to you too
much
thank you
you've grown so much you've done a lot
of uh mental exercises
you know
caitlin you're starting to rock now
started to run back and forth
a lot of mind games i have to play with
myself
um
no honestly it's mostly like i just have
to have some
like safe zones in the house that don't
get messy yeah what's the safe zone
it's a living room
and the living room hasn't even been
safe recently every now and then it's
been pretty safe yeah that's kind of the
only one
the main area of the house isn't too bad
aside from the kitchen counter yeah
which is where we put all the packages
and stuff that come in it's like you
just gotta we even we even thought okay
we we actually have a whole room it used
to be a workout room and now it's our
equipment room where we store all of our
cameras and tripods and lights it's the
cit room i.t room it's literally like an
i.t room like i had family over at some
point and they walked in and they're
like
is this the i.t room and i'm like yeah
kind of yeah your sister was like i feel
like i'm at like an office i.t room
right that's exactly what this is yeah
this house is an office this is a
like about half of our house is all
dedicated to work things
um
but yeah we you know we we we moved in
and we got everything functional but
we've again being like we've left like a
kale of a trail of like kind of chaos
behind our behind us we've gotten
everything to a point of just good
enough
yes and it's kind of just stayed there
yes and at the last house that's how it
was until we until we moved well it was
a little different at the last house it
started good yeah and then it gradually
got more and more chaotic
because we
um
had to get a lot of stuff over the
course of a few years of running our
business
either because
we were
um adding on new parts of our business
like streaming you know like you need a
lot of stuff to do that we've spread
into an entire room just for streaming
now two rooms two rooms two rooms yeah
um
or um
you know the collection of tools grows
or also just the fact that like we're
making stuff so
every time we make something new we have
a new thing
and we often have bought a bunch of
materials and tools and accessories in
order to make that thing so
um
the old house it started out
at just like a fine neutral place
remember our guest room at the old house
used to actually have like a normal pad
in it yeah wow yeah it was before the 3d
printers and stuff wow yeah the only
chaos room was your office
so i guess there always was a little bit
of chaos but i could just shut that door
yeah it was just one room yeah at one
point it was all contained in one room
yeah
and then it's just spread
yeah i mean there's there's literally
piles
in in every room we even like one of the
reasons why we wanted this house is
because
it had more space
and we could like kind of have areas
dedicated towards
kind of just piles of our stuff and like
the original idea was just having that
one it room the storage room being the
place where like when we get packages we
like walk it back to the room and we
have a table yeah we were gonna have a
table in that room for instance incoming
packages that we were gonna process into
our storage solutions i know
and they're still in the kitchen counter
well we don't have that table well we
had that table it got filled up with
like uv lights and cameras the table is
in there it's just full
it's always full there's you know
horizontal surfaces are so dangerous i
would really like to
organize the house this year
i really had a reasonable goal
yeah i think let's do it
let's talk about 2022 goals oh yeah
organize the house
i think that if we like buckled down
and spent like
seven full days
tackling the house
we could get it to like a level one
okayness
and by level one okayness is like
like like in my head
these are things that like i've talked
about with caitlyn that i that aren't
like
necessarily obvious to anyone like
hearing it so level zero is like
it's it's barely it's functional but
it's not at all at a place where we like
where we're happy with it to me level
one is like without buying a ton of big
things or doing a ton of like research
rabbit holes or anything like that let's
take advantage of what we have right now
and put everything up put everything
away put everything tidy all the stuff
that's out that isn't being used put it
away and to me that's like level one and
the level two is like taking the time to
like find the right optimal storage
solutions and
doing things right
so yeah i think for me i struggle with
that sometimes yeah because um you kind
of want to go straight to level two yeah
i always kind of want to go straight to
level two and i think the reason for
that is
you know a level one example is just
like
you have empty cabinets just put stuff
in the cabinets and you can organize it
later
my fear is if you put stuff in the
cabinets to organize it later that later
is going to come
much later
because it's away and you forget about
it you forget what you put in there what
you just like shoved in there randomly
yeah so for me i'd almost rather just
have it out and painful painful and
bothering me
but where like i know where it is i'm
not going to forget about it and then
do the full solution yeah but the full
solution
takes longer yeah and i think that the
reason why i'm pushing for level one
first
and i'm not pushing you know i'm okay
for i'm okay with either one but i just
i just know my we've done a little bit
of both i know my wife and i know that
she is gonna spend about
i don't even i don't even want to put an
hour
hour
amount on it but you're going to put
hours and hours and hours of research
into every thing which is right and
that's what it kind of deserves but i do
worry that i'm not sure if we have that
much time
yeah
yeah
struggle that's the struggle
yeah but that is a goal that's a goal so
okay so get our house
to like at least level one maybe level
two goodness
[Laughter]
that would be pretty epic i think for me
my goal is to
not get too caught up in setting up the
house and i want to like just like
do non-work life stuff
that sounds nice too yeah
like go to movie
yeah i think that that's a certain
degree we've been so caught up with
um work and it's so easy to default with
work because that's been like our
default for four years out of necessity
out of necessity and i think that it's
been very rewarding and i love it and
i'm very happy for like with how things
have gone and the success that we've
found i'm totally worth it i love it
love i love it also i don't i don't want
this to sound like
we like don't like our work we really
like our work we just are observing that
like in order to not
burn out we we have to kind of
constantly fight this tendency to do
more and more work because we like it
because we like it we don't want to burn
out yeah yeah you want to keep doing it
yeah it's really fun yeah it's really
really fun and i think that's that
that's again going back to like why a
lot of
you know
a lot of people have a tendency to like
you know
go too hard into just all youtube is
because it's it's fun
it's rewarding there's a challenge and
reward payout because i think that's one
thing that i often think of too you know
i
like things where there's a challenge i
like things whereas there's a challenge
like in like in video games like like if
if um
you know like you know we've been
playing a lot of seven days to dice
that's what i think of it's like a
zombie survival horror game you start
out with nothing
and you like punch trees and gather
rocks and you build an ax and you get a
better thing you find more things and
like if at the very beginning of the
game you were infinitely high level and
you had everything available to you if
you didn't have to like work for the
success that you find in the game it
wouldn't be enjoyable yeah and i think
that for life
you know there's also like
a certain extra enjoyment when you work
hard for something and you achieve
something and you can enjoy it so i
think that's another reason why it's so
so easy to just keep on giving more into
into your work
when it's your own business and it's
rewarding for you
um
but yeah i think that that i'm excited
to like
you know
i think that
like the more you put into something the
easier it is to put more into that thing
and we've been putting so much into work
and we love it but i kind of want to try
putting
more time and effort into non-work so
that we can find other things that we
enjoy so then we can put more time into
that and we'll have this motivation
to break from work more frequently yeah
it's like get a better balance get a
better balance yeah i think that that
would be
good so i think those are our two main
goals for 2022
yeah we like to keep goals pretty
well i guess organizing the house is
kind of specific but yeah um you know
it's a really boring goal what working
working out
i do want to work out more
i really do i really do probably not a
smart idea right now with the covid and
all
yeah
maybe we could try what if we just do
some stretching yeah i'm down that
that's actually a huge trick that we've
found
to to work for us to get us to work out
we're like let's just stretch for five
minutes
and we end up working out for 20 minutes
yeah then that might not seem like much
once a week
but you know
hey sometimes we do
excuse me
sometimes we do it more than once a week
yeah
twice
for 20 minutes
hey sometimes we go for 35.
rare rare
rare
we do like we actually do enjoy working
out once we do it
but you know
sometimes like by the time you're done
working you're so sleepy yeah you know
yeah um
our other secret is we have a show that
will we're only allowed to watch while
we work out yes and we rotate what that
show is but
yeah we have a workout only show so if
it's been too long we're like oh man we
gotta go work out so we can watch the
show we don't want to get too behind
lose track
yeah where we are yeah what's going on
exactly
right now we're watching the
bachelorette yeah
um
yeah
any other thoughts unlike the
unsustainable path that that youtubers
often start out with i like i think that
for me i don't want to like give too
many examples because that's not our
story to tell
you know what i mean
yeah but there's you know there's so
many people you can find who talk about
how they've had to shift their schedules
or talk about how they have burnt out
because they didn't shift their schedule
or things just got um they just kept
adding and adding oh i have one other
thing that i want to add to that to that
topic
i think that's another reason why we
started
evan and caitlin
ii
and evan and katelyn uncut
and even going back farther um
the gaming channel yeah yeah it might
seem counterintuitive like why do we
start these other types of channels
like if you want to reduce your work
how come you don't just like put out
less videos on the main channel yeah
instead we've kind of
gradually slightly slowed the amount of
videos on the main channel but also
greatly increasing the amount of videos
on
the gaming channel especially but then
we also started doing them on the second
channel but it's because like
i think part of not burning out and like
preventing that ahead of time
for us is getting to
do and try a variety of different things
and sometimes we feel like doing a resin
project but sometimes we just feel like
making weird rice krispies yeah you know
like we actually do games we actually
have a stream plan should we mention
that the stream we have coming up
like that we're gonna do once we get a
little bit better i mean with the
caveats of we don't know when it's going
to happen or if it's going to happen it
might not we're going to make makeup
yeah and
are you going to put it on you or am i
going to put it on here i think you
should try putting it on is that going
to be no but i want to do a whole video
where i just try to do your makeup with
real makeup okay then i can do it we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out yeah
but there's these ideas that kids
make makeup
or no you should put makeup on me
maybe that could be its own whole video
too that could be there's so many
there's so many things that we want to
do and i i just like you know the reason
why we don't want to put it on our main
channel is because we want like for our
own sake and and
and um you know for also like
expectations of sponsors
we want our main channel to be a certain
level of
views that we can expect and with these
more experimental fun videos we don't
want us we don't want the stress of how
they're going to perform
to affect our enjoyment of creating the
videos or to prevent us from doing it
and we have tried putting more
experimental videos on the main channel
like we tried doing cooking videos on
the main channel yeah and it
it was fine
um
we kind of we noticed that we stopped
doing them because like they did they
were always like the number 10 out of 10
last place
and it kind of made us like if we're
going to put all this time and effort
into a video
like and put a sponsor on it and risk
like disappointing that sponsor like uh
you know we should just do
like there's so many other things that
we're excited about let's just do one of
those other things yeah and we stopped
doing the cooking videos but then we
realized if we just put them on the
second channel
doesn't really matter yeah
the views that they get as much and so
we're more likely to do them yeah so i
know it might be a little confusing like
why we put certain things on the main
versus the second
um and why we even have a second channel
but
i think it's just like
internally you have an idea of like
how is this video gonna do
and based on how we think it's gonna do
we choose what channel it's going to be
on there's some other kind of internal
rules
we have for ourselves too yeah um
but yeah it just helps us like be able
to experiment a bit more yeah so you
think like okay you want to prevent
burnout so why are you making more
channels but the reason why we're making
more channels
is to continue doing things that we
enjoy so we don't burn out
yeah yeah
we like variety it keeps it spicy yeah
right is the spiciness of life it
certainly is that's a wise quote yeah we
should put that on a t-shirt keep it
spicy
keep it spicy guys he was spicy
everybody
i think i might be down to it to move to
thing of the week isn't spicy used if
something's like not safe for work a
little spicy isn't that
i think that's used to describe things
aren't they like more raunchy
yeah yeah but spicy spicy keep it spicy
everybody anyways thing of the week
[Music]
wow we have some things things of the
week well i wrote down a lot we don't
have to do all of them
i'm just let's just do all of them okay
yeah things of the things of the week
my
my number one favorite thing of the week
that i haven't shared with you guys yet
are
flavor packets
for water i've been on a very specific
brand i have been on a hunt
for so long
to find like because i uh you guys might
not know this about me but i generally
don't like water unless it's at night
and i'm going to sleep
i'm going to look up the
specific ones we get because like i feel
like true citrus true lemon
something i don't know
i'll just search it you can talk about
them and why they're different
i'll pull up on your phone because
you're signed in there i got it okay
that is it true lemonade
okay but it started with the lemon true
lemon is the the the specific lemon one
i think that the company or something is
like
interesting anyways the links are going
to be in the description
yeah is the company
um
and uh yeah so i've been on a hunt for
like something to make water taste
better but all of the little squeeze
bottles all the flavoring packets all of
it they taste wrong they taste unnatural
and i've never enjoyed a single one
until i found this brand i'm pointing at
it but it's not on screen
and it's it's uh
it's it's really tasty yeah i like it i
like multiple flavors it's like
the lemon one is the one we started with
and i still think the lemon is the best
but they also have like lemon mint lemon
cucumber lemon raspberry grapefruit they
have
a bunch of different things
oh yeah i've just pulled it up there you
go
there you go that's what it looks like
um
but uh
oh yeah and you're pulling up all day
yeah but it's it's it's great and uh and
i just keep it in my fanny pack yes i
have a fanny pack yeah i keep some of my
purse because i like carrying lots of
fun things in my fanny pack yes and um
uh and it's great you can just add it to
your drinks
what's next
well i was gonna say specifically if you
look at the ingredients it's like
citric acid is it citric acid it's like
dehydrated dehydrated lemon
lemon
yeah
anyways it's awesome also i just
realized we have a lot of beverage
related
are you reading the ingredients it's
like
that's too small
yeah but it's like natural
yeah so i i really like it it's it's the
best one i've ever found and
and um if if you are a non-fl uh water
lover like me is great
we have a lot of beverage
items i don't want to pull them all up
we'll link to them i don't want to pull
them all up behind us okay but um uh
kaitlyn for for a recent uh a gift for
me
um she knows that i have been having a
lot of caffeine intolerance it just
keeps me up late at night and i don't
know if you have it in the morning even
if i have it in the morning i used to be
able to have caffeine until like three
and now even if i have caffeine at
eleven
i i i just get like heart palpitations
and i just can't i just can't have any
caffeine which is sad so um
um so i found um a really really really
good decaf um coffee coffee yeah yeah
it's from uh stone street coffee it's
their um mayan swiss water
uh decaf
it's really really good it tastes just
like normal coffee yeah like and i'm
also someone like
caffeine doesn't really
keep me awake but it also doesn't wake
me up
so i'm
fine with decaf as long as it tastes
good but i make um like
lattes essentially with decaf coffee
and it's the first decaf i've tried that
the flavor can get strong enough to add
that much milk to it because i do like
you know
it's like one-third coffee and like
two-thirds milk and you need a really
strong coffee for it to actually still
have a coffee flavor and it holds up
um so we will link that as well are we
also going to talk about our decaf tea
yes my mom found some awesome deca decaf
tea which i also love it's like super
tasty flavored it's like mango something
we don't need to say much about it it's
decaf tea we'll put a link you know we
didn't look up all the brand names
before this but like there will be links
in the description okay so i think that
what we can pause there we'll save the
other ones for later we'll keep this the
beverage
we'll keep this the beverage themed
thing of the week yeah so if you need
decaf things or you don't like the taste
of water
check out our links in the description
and i think that we're going to end here
a little bit shorter than our usual
podcast just to like you know make sure
we're not
you know constraining our voices too
much and uh hopefully we'll be able to
do another podcast when we're not sick
we're not sick thanks as always for
tuning in and hanging out with us and
watching or listening to our content and
look forward to seeing you in the next
one bye
foreign